Welcome to the end William.
Welcome to the end of the world everyone
it's Charlie. This is going to be my
westworld season 3 episode 8 finale
video there were a bunch of easter eggs
and we got a really big post-credits
scene to sort of tease what's going to
be happening in season four so we'll
break it all down
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet we'll do top 10
and easter eggs as we go along
there's a lot of stuff to cover the
episode was extra long but that's
because there was so much stuff to wrap
up and so much stuff to tease for their
season 4 story
so starting with number 10 the title of
the episode crisis
theory obviously that's a reference to
the crisis that's breaking out all over
the place the world is erupting into
chaos it's going to burn itself to the
ground as they pretty much imply at
several points in the episode but they
keep referring to the idea of the world
burning itself down just letting that
happen
so that the new world can be born from
the ashes so number nine the dolores
flashbacks the episodes start with the
flashback scene of ford
questioning dolores taking a bigger role
for herself in her own narrative whether
or not she'd be the hero that story the
villain of that story
it's from the earlier seasons they sort
of change it a little bit and give it
some new dialogue
in the context of what's been happening
during season three they're just making
you question whether or not dolores has
really been the villain this whole time
or whether she's been the hero
really it's a more complicated answer
because even though we find out what's
really going on with Serac and rehoboam
later in the episode
both dolores and rehoboam have their own
plans for saving the human race
i love the way that bernard sort of
contextualizes that plan later in the
episode making you question
whether or not rehoboam was ever really
necessary in the first place
the world was always going to burn
itself down rehoboam and sorak were just
postponing that
this needed to happen the world needed
to eat itself alive
but then number eight welcome back
lawrence so man in black wants to kill
stubs and bernard we pick up where they
left off in last week's episode
he gets a real good shot into stubs and
you do kind of wonder what's going on
with him now
based on the way they end with bernard
in that final scene did he ever get out
of that bathtub or is he still
chilling out drinking that cheap booze
we don't really find out what lawrence
gives bernard to later in the episode
but he tells bernard that he has the
most important role to play because he
has the key to the data inside his head
in the ability to bring
all those people back he tells bernard
here's something to help you on the
journey that you're on something to help
complete your task he does the same
thing for man in black during season one
although it's much more confrontational
when man in black did it back during
season one the number seven welcome back
to loris so we find out the caleb's
being led to this warehouse where
dolores has stashed another copy of a
body
but it's actually one of the original
bodies with the metal skeleton
that's meant to be a callback to the
montage at the beginning of the episode
where they sort of show you dolores
history as she slowly went through all
those different roles at the park the
different narratives
the other important reason why dolores
probably gave herself this older body is
because as she says later when she's
fighting maeve i was built to last
you're all copies of me
so she's using this body specifically
because it's that much stronger she
could have stashed any body she wanted
to in this warehouse
kayla gets pissed off because he feels
like dolores knows everything that he's
going to do we don't
find out exactly why that is till later
but dolores sort of fills him in
well when you were in the military being
trained as a soldier they used a lot of
delos built hosts to train them
and while that was happening delos was
downloading all this information on them
the same way that it does with the host
so remember the concept of the forge in
the human immortality project
delos did the same thing with all these
military people so it seems like dolores
read quote-unquote caleb's book inside
the forge
so she knew all about him and knew that
he could be a good person
like they say she chose him because of
his capacity to choose
you've done some crappy stuff you've
done some good stuff but ultimately you
are capable of making a choice
and that's a bit of a contrast to sorak
in the episode who says he completely
gave up his ability to choose giving
himself over to rehoboam
we'll talk about that in a second too
there were a lot of you that had
theories about what was really going on
with rehoboam and sorak
but then we go back to man in black
number six he tries to get access to his
money we find out he's way
richer now because of Serac's buyout of
delos
but then he says he wants a list of all
the delos assets
all over the world basically like delos
bat caves like we see in the post credit
scene at the end of the episode he wants
to find out where they are and obviously
that's going to tie into the season 4
storyline but up until the post-credits
scene he says it's his mission to erase
the host from the face of the earth now
obviously that plan goes really sideways
during the post-credits scene so we'll
talk about that in a second too
what's really going to happen now with
the man in black number five
dolores versus charlotte delores i think
we actually found our real villain
during season four here like we've been
having conversations about who the real
villain of season three is if there is a
real villain
i think charlotte is going to wind up being
the main antagonist for season four
just based on the way they leave things
the reason why she's able to digitally
project herself to delores's mind so
that only dolores can see her like caleb
doesn't see any of this stuff going on
like who are you talking to he doesn't
see charlotte standing there
that's because of the way dolores is
linked to all the different copies of
herself she did that so that she can
enact her plan
dolores kind of makes a joke about it
while it's all going down because
caleb's like are these
rocks men that are coming for us and
she's like nope it's some of my people
coming after us
they have a big callback joke about the
ricoh app you remember in last week's
episode
they revealed how rehoboam would
manipulate the ricoh app to get people
to turn on each other and that's what
happened between caleb and his friend
played by kid cudi
he turned on him because he was offered
more money dolores does the exact same
thing in order to get them out of this
spot
but just as they do maeve rolls up in
full ninja gear
so number four dolores versus maeve i
believe this is round three they have a
couple really good fights during the
episode but it's the finale so you kind
of expect things to be taken to the
extreme
she taunts dolores with teddy what are
you going to turn this guy into your next
teddy
the thing is bernard actually is
probably speaking to teddy by the end of
the episode because he uploads himself
into that place
the way they contextualize caleb's role
in all this is that dolores has been
setting him up or at least
advertising him as the leader of the
revolution against in sight
so if we're talking about terminator
metaphors here think about the
terminator franchise you have this
post-apocalyptic environment heading
into season four
the machines being led by charlotte and
then the people being led by john connor
caleb
they really do kind of seem like they're
going full terminator into season four
one of the cool reveals during their
first fight though in this episode is
when she says to maeve you're all
copies of me all the other hosts the way
she explains it is that after the
original revolt
when she went full wyatt on arnold ford
and delos started revising all the newer
copies of the hosts
based on dolores and dolores really is
the original host but then just as she
defeats maven combat
she's actually hacked by the charlotte
version of dolores who says that she's
using delors's own systems that she set
up against her
the number three big twist bernard goes
to meet arnold's former wife who's
played by gina taurus wearing old person
makeup
if you remember gina taurus was actually
featured as bernard's wife during season
one
before we knew that he was a host it was
sort of a fake broadcast that they did
where they were talking about their
grief over their son and they had
separated
in that version of events it was implied
that they've been divorced for a while
which i think is true to life i think at
some point arnold did get separated from
his family like he says i think i came
here to
reconcile and make amends for what i did
the way i left things with my family
and even though he's not really arnold
he has a lot of arnold's memories so he
believes that charlie really was his son
and he lost him so all that pain and
grief is real for him
she helps him work through that and that
sort of gives him the idea that he has
at the end of the episode to upload his
consciousness into that special place
where all the hosts are being stored to
get an idea for what's supposed to
happen next
after the end of the world as he says it
the number two caleb destroys rehoboam
with dolores help so even though it
seemed like the plan did not go
according to dolores plan she secretly
sort of engineered things so that it
would go down this way
it does make you wonder what was on that
thumb drive if anything was on it
the way that maeve explains it at the
end of the episode is that solomon's
final plan was actually
inside dolores in when she was uploaded
into the rehoboam system
that's how they were able to lock out
sorak and give sole access to caleb's
soul control who was then able
to get rehoboam to delete itself the
speech that dolores goes out on talking
to maeve is meant to be a mirror for the
speech she had at the beginning of the
episode i choose to see the beauty
it's the same speech that she had in
previous seasons so a lot of these
dolores scenes and the flashbacks are
all meant to call back to her flashbacks
in earlier seasons
while this is all going down though one
of the bigger reveals is that sorak has
actually been a finger puppet
of rehoboam this whole time there were a
lot of you that had theories about
whether or not sorak was actually a real
person or if he was just a projection of
rehoboam
the way they explained it during the
episode is that he was a real person but
he was just
allowing rehoboam to tell him what to do
so he would just
literally wait for rehoboam to tell him
what to say at every turn
just waiting for commands say this next
then say this next
then this so the fact that sorak gave up
his ability to choose or his right to
choose is meant to be a contrast to what
dolores said earlier the reason why you
were chosen caleb is because of your
ability to choose
so the whole idea in shutting down
rehoboam is that caleb's saying i'm
giving the human race
the ability to choose their own future
but the way that bernard talks about it
is that the human race was always going
to burn itself to the ground eventually
and they needed to let it happen
in order for something better to be born
from the ashes
the way they talk about bringing back
all those people from the forge all the
hosts that uploaded themselves at the
end of season two the place where
bernard goes in the post-credits scene
also kind of implies that they might be
able to bring dolores or a version of
dolores back at some point
then as they walk outside and start
watching buildings blowing up around
them in los angeles they start playing
pink floyd's brain damage
and maeve tells caleb the same speech
that she used to tell new guests at the
saloon in westworld this is the new
world and in this world you can be
anyone you want so obviously they're
going to explore that quote-unquote new
world which sounds very post-apocalyptic
during season four
number one is obviously the many
different post-credits scenes so there's
a lot of stuff that happens after the
credits
man in black arrives at the delos base
in dubai wearing all black again he's
gone full man in black
we find charlotte in the basement
printing all these copies of host so
think of her
as the skynet in this situation printing
all these brand new terminators
then she reveals that she's copied man
in black and turned him into a host who
then proceeds to seemingly kill him even
though he slits his throat we don't
actually see him die
so it is possible for the real william
to come back during season four we don't
really know what happens to him it just
implied that he died
welcome to the end william and if you've
seen the future world movie which was a
sequel to the westworld movie
that was actually a bit of a plot during
that with him replacing real people
with hoes then the very final scene is
bernard
coming back to his body from that
digital forge space where all the copies
were stored they were trying to find
during the season
but because he's covered in all that
dust it's implied that a lot of time has
gone
by maybe even years it's kind of hard to
tell how much time exactly
we'll have to wonder what happened to
stubs if he's still chilling out in that
tub or if he eventually climbed out of
his own accord
but they have renewed the show for
season four because of the virus delays
i'm assuming they're not going to start
filming that till either
the end of this year or early next year
at some point so we're probably not
going to see
westworld season 4 until 2022
everyone let me know in the comments
what was your favorite part of the
episode or if you spotted any really big
easter eggs that i didn't mention during
the video
there's a ton of stuff happening
tomorrow for may the 4th rick and morty
is back with new episodes so my new rick
and morty episode will be the next video
that i post tomorrow morning
while you wait for that click here for
my brand new avengers infinity saga
deleted scene of dr strange becoming
iron man
and click here for all my westworld
episodes thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!